Puerto Rico no gana para disgustos.
Si no fuera suficiente con la salvaje crisis
económica que padece desde hace ya más de
una década, su declaración de bancarrota,
y los huracanes Irma y María que en el 2017
arrasaron la isla, ahora se suman los terremotos.
Más de 2000 movimientos sísmicos registrados
que comenzarón en 2019 y que se están prolongando
en 2020.
[Vamos, que ya no se que más le puede pasar
a la isla
Suerte, lo que se dice suerte, pues precisamente
no están teniendo.]
Ahora bien, con todo lo que más llama la
atención es que en ocasiones este lugar  parece
más un territorio del África Subsahariana
que de los mismísimos Estados Unidos.
Un momento, ¿qué por qué digo tal cosa?
Fijaos.
(El huracan María causó un enorme caos del
que la isla más de 2 años después aún
no se ha recuperado.
Y ojo porque no solo hablamos de las más
de 3.000 vidas perdidas.
El huracan dejó la isla sin electricidad
durante semanas. Incluso, en algunas zonas
la electricidad no se restableció hasta pasados
11 meses.
Destruyó más de 90 mil casas y los daños
a las infraestructuras fueron enormes.)
Y vamos a ver, seamos honestos:
que un huracan cause daños es algo que entra
dentro de lo previsible. Qué las consecuencias
tarden años en arreglarse y el caos sea generalizado…
Eso ya no es tan normal.
Al menos no debería serlo en un territorio
que pertenece a los mismísmos Estados Unidos,
¿No os parece?
[Ojo, Qué estamos hablando en algunos casos
de casi 1 año sin electricidad. ¡Un año!
Que esas cosas pasen en el tercer mundo…
Pues se entiende, pero… ¿En los Estados
Unidos? ¿De verdad? De locos.]
El caso, amigos, es que toda esta destrucción
llegó por si fuera poco en un momento particularmente
dificil para Puerto Rico.
Cómo ya os contamos en un vídeo que os dejo
en la descripción, apenas un par de años
antes, en 2015 el gobierno de la Isla se había
declarado en bancarrota y la situación económica
era mala, muy mala. Y para colmo te viene
no uno sino 2 huracanes.
Y eso es precisamente de lo que os vamos a hablar
en ese vídeo. De cómo es el Puerto Rico
post-María, de cómo se afrontó la situación
y de que futuro podemos esperar para una isla
que está atravesando el que tal vez es el
peor momento de su historia reciente.
Atentos.
(EL RASTRO DE MARÍA: MÁS ALLÁ DE LAS CIFRAS)
Dos huracanes enormes en menos de un mes.
Primero el huracan Irma golpeo a la Isla de
perfil y más tarde el Huracan María la golpeo
de lleno. Fue algo así como el gancho final
a un boxeador que está a punto del K.O.
Ahora bien, cómo todos sabéis, Puerto Rico
es una isla caribeña, es decir está muy
expuesta a este tipo de fenomenos.
Y es normal que los huracanes causen daños.
Eso está claro.
La cuestión es que teniendo en cuenta su
renta per capita y su nivel de desarrollo,
la isla sufrió consecuencias mucho mayores
de las que debería haber sufrido.
Y la pregunta qué nos tenemos que hacer es…
¿Por qué demonios estos huracanes causaron
tantos daños? ¿No estaba acaso preparada
la isla para hacer frente a contingencias
de este tipo? ¿Por qué se tardó tanto en
reparar los deterioro? Y eso cuando los arreglaron.
En definitiva, ¿Qué diantres pasa con Puerto
Rico?. Esa, esa amigos, es la pregunta.
(Para entender mejor lo que ocurre en esta
isla podemos echar un vistazo a lo que ocurrió
con el sistema eléctrico tras el paso del
Huracan María.
Que una zona concreta de un territorio se
quede sin electicidad tras el paso de un huracan
es algo comprensible y hasta cierto punto
norma.
Sin embargo que se quede sin electricidad
una isla entera del tamaño de Puerto Rico
con más de 3 millones de habitantes, eso
ya es muy distinto. Es algo que nos da ciertas
pistas acerca de que las cosas no marchaban
precisamente bien antes del huracan.
Y lo cierto es que exactamente por ahí van
los tiros.
La infraestructura electrica puertorriqueña
se encontraba en un estado desastroso. Un
estado propio de un país del tercer mundo
pero nunca de un Estado libre asociado de
los Estados Unidos.)
De esta forma, debido a la mala previsión
y sobre todo al mal mantenimiento, la tempestad
tumbó al menos una cuarta parte de las torres
de transmisión eléctrica e inutilizo el
40% de las subestaciones.
El resultado fue la más absoluta oscuridad.
Y es que para colmo los sistemas de producción
electrica y los principales centros de consumo
estan a lados opuestos de la isla.
Es decir, mientras el 70% de las centrales
fósiles se encuentran en la zona sur, el
Precisamente esa distribución exige que las
conexiones estén bien protegidas, algo que
como veis no tenía nada que ver con la situación
real de la isla.
De hecho, la propia linea de alta tensión
que conecta los centros de producción con
los centros de consumo fue destrozada por
el paso de del Huracán.
En resumen, unos daños enormes, exagerados
cuya reparación llevó mucho tiempo.
Ahora bien, puede que llegados a este punto
muchos estéis pensando… Pero Enrique, ¿por
qué tanta insistencia con el sistema eléctrico
de Puerto Rico?
Pues amigos, porque lo que estamos viendo
es algo así cómo una prueba de esfuerzo,
un ejercicip una muestra que nos permite ver
las patalogias que realmente se esconden tras
los problemas por los que atraviesa este lugar.
Y ojo, no solo en Puerto Rico, también en
otros muchos lugares de Latinoamerica.
Atentos.
(UN COLAPSO ANUNCIADO)
Amigos, el sistema eléctrico puertorirqueño
ha sido esencialmente un sistema público
desde los años 40.
De hecho, una empresa del gobierno, la Autoridad
de Energía Elctrica tuvo el monopolío de
la distribución y la producción eléctrica
hasta el año 2010.
Y con mucha diferencia, hoy sigue siendo el
actor más importante de la isla.
Y también un fiel reflejo de todo lo que
ocurre en este lugar.
Fijaos, en el 2017 esta empresa pública monopolística
entró en bancarrota.
[Y mira que es dificil quebrar a una empresa
que tiene el monopolio sobre un servicio básico.
Pues… Sí, eso es exactamente lo que paso.]
El caso es que lo hizo pocos meses después
de la propia declaración de bancarrota del
gobierno de Puerto Rico, la mayor bancarrota
de la historia de los administraciones públicas
de Estados Unidos.
Y, amigos, las razones de ambas declaraciones
de bancarrota fueron practicamente las mismas.
Por un lado, el derroche, la falta de responsabilidad
y la incompetencia de los políticos locales
jugo un papel esencial.
[No nos engañemos al final el primer responsable
siempre está en casa.]
Pero en este caso no fueron los únicos. En
cierto modo ya os lo hemos contado aquí en
VisualPolitik.
En ambas bancarrotas los Estados Unidos tuvieron
buena parte de la responsabilidad.
Sí, sí, los Estados Unidos.
(Ya os lo hemos contado en alguna que otra
ocasión. La situación de enorme precariedad
en la que se encuentra Puerto Rico se debe,
además de al mal gobierno isleño y a la
corrupción, al maltraro legal al que Estados
Unidos somete a este territorio semicolonial.
En el caso de la Autoridad de Energía Eléctrica,
la bancarrota del 2017, apenas unos meses
antes del paso de Irma y María, se debió
fundamentalmente a la supreción en 1996 de
la sección 936 del Código de Rentas Internas
del gobierno federal de Estados Unidos.
¿Y qué decía esta sección? Pues basicamente
otorgaba exenciones en los impuestos federales
para la empresas localizadas en territorios
bajo control de Estados Unidos, como Puerto
Rico.
Pues bien, en el caso que nos atañe, en el
de esta isla caribeña, se estableció un
periodo de gracia de 10 años como trancisión
hasta la eliminación todal de esos incentivos
ficales. Proceso que fue culminado en el año
2005.)
Vale, os hago una pregunta. ¿Que pensais
que pasó despues?... Exacto, apenas unos
meses después estalló una enorme crisis.
La huida de Puerto Rico de todo tipo de inversiones,
especialmente las inversiones industriales
fue enorme.
Para que os hagais una idea el 60%, ojo el
60% de los clientes industriales de la compañía
eléctrica se marcharon de la isla.
Por supuesto esto hizo crecer el desempleo,
la economía informal y la pobreza como la
espuma.
Y todo esto combinado hundió el consumo eléctrico.
Algo que a su vez causó un enorme deterioro
en las cuentas de la empresa pública.
Y si su gestión ya era peor que
mala, ahora cómo veis tenían que lidiar
además con una enorme caída de ingresos. Un agujero de proporciones épicas.
(De esta forma, la Autoridad de Energía Électrica
no solo empezó a devorar enormes cantidades
de deuda, sino que cualquier plan de modernización,
transformación e incluso mantenimiento no
urgente quedo aparcado.
De hecho, la empresa tuvo que aplicar incluso
recortes en las tareas de mantenimiento ordinarias.
Y aun así nada fue suficiente para evitar
que 10 años despues se declarará en quiebra)
Es decir, para que nos entendamos, hablamos
de una empresaque fue hundida por la gestión
de los políticos puertoriqueños y también
por las decisiones de los políticos de Washington.
Un cocktel explosivo.
Y eso mismo es lo que ha pasado exactamente
con toda la isla.
Tal vez que los puertoriqueños no tengan
ni voz ni voto en las elecciones presidenciales
y legislativas de los Estados Unidos tenga
algo que ver.
[Y no me conteis la milonga de que eligen
a una especie de portavoz para que les represente
en el Congreso. No os engañeis, si no tiene
voto no cuenta.]
Amigos, Puerto Rico es algo así como un territorio
completamente olvidado por los Estados Unidos…
A pesar de que formalmente es Estados Unidos;
o mejor dicho: está bajo el dominio de la
superpotencia norteamericana.
Lo que sí parece claro es que los
políticos de Washington no se fían nada,
pero que nada de los políticos puertoriqueños.
[Y vale, dados los antecedes de corrupción,
el mal uso de fondos público y su pésima gestión
es algo comprensible. Pero es que tampoco
hacen mucho por no decir nada por cambiar
la situación.]
(Una prueba de toda esta enorme desconfiaza
la pudimos ver tras el impacto del huracan
María.
En ese momento, el Congreso de los Estados
Unidos, entonces de mayoría republica, y
de acuerdo en todo momento con la Administración
Trump, obligó a Puerto Rico a crear un plan
de reconstrucción que sería estrechamente
fiscalizado por la Junta de Supervisión Fiscal,
un organismo federal creado tras la declaración
de bancarrota de la isla para controlar las
cuentas del gobierno.
Pero, no contentos con eso, además impusieron
una serie de normas muy exigentes y practicamente
sin precedentes: por ejemplo todo contrato
superior a los 10 millones de dólares para
la reconstrucción tenía que ser supervisado
minuciosamente por esa junta.
Algo que puede sonar muy bien pero que sin
embargo en este caso causó un enorme problema:
la Junta no es precisamente el organismo más
rápido en llevar a cabo sus tareas.
Es decir, lo que en la práctica hizo el Congreso
fue burocratizar hasta unos niveles asfixiantes
todas las tareas de reconstrucción.)
Vamos, que lo que  podía ser una buena idea se acabo convirtiendo en un infierno burocrático.
(Puerto Rico fue golpeado por el huracán
María, arruinado por la negligencia de la
Agencia Federal para el Manejo de Emergicas
- FEMA - y vilipendiado por Trump - USA Today)
Y ahí no termina todo.
Otro ejemplo lo tenemos en los requisitos
extraordinarios y sin precedentes que se impusieron
a la Agencia Federal para el Manejo de Emergencias
(FEMA) y al Departamento de Vivienda y Desarrollo
Urbano (HUD), es decir a las dos agencias
federales encargadas de distribuir y gestionar
los fondos para la recuperación en caso de
catástrofes.
Y es que veréis, entre otras cosas en abril
del 2018 el gobierno federral le impuso a
estas agencias un límite de gasto que no
podía ser superior en ningún caso a la estimación
de costes que hiciera el gobierno de Puerto
Rico para la reconstrucción.
Es decir, se querían evitar a toda costa
los sobre costes.
De esta forma, si durante el proceso aparecían
imprevistos o situaciones inesperadas… Ajo
y agua que se dice en España. Puerto Rico
tendría que aguantarse.
Seguro que esto a muchos os puede parecer
muy bien, ¿verdad? Al menos hasta que caeis
en la cuenta de que es toda una invitación
a sobrevalorar los daños e inflar los presupuestos
de reconstrucción….Qué es exactamente
lo que hizo el gobierno de Puerto Rico.
Pero eso nos llevaría a otro debate que supera
el objetivo de este vídeo. El caso amigos
es que tal y cómo veis durante todo el proceso
dio la sensación de que el gobierno federal
estaba más preocupado de lo que los politicos
que de la propia reconstrucción de la isla.
Ahora bien, ¿Se les puede culpar por ello?
¿A que demonios se debe tanta desconfianza?
Atentos.
(PUERTO RICO, DE MAL EN PEOR)
Por supuesto, los problemas de Puerto
Rico no solo provienen de las leyes federales
que son incapaces de adaptarse a la realidad
puertoriqueña. Decir tal cosa sería faltar
a la verdad.
Lo cierto es que durante muchos años, los
gobiernos isleños, han pasado olimpicamente
de los gravísimos problemas financieros que
tenía la isla y se dedicaron basivamente
a pedir más y más dinero al Congreso de
los Estados Unidos.
Los propios huracanes nos dejaron alguna muestra
de la más absoluta falta de capacidad. ¿Quereis
un ejemplo? Fijaos en lo que paso en las semanas
siguientes a la catastrofe.
(En Puerto Rico, contenedores llenos de mercancías
permanecen en los puertos sin ser distribuidos
- National Public Radio)
Y amigos, no penseis ni por un instante que
hablamos de casos aislados.
Hace nada, el pasado enero de 2020, se descubrió
en un almacén numerosos palés de ayuda humanitaria
del huracán María, por supuesto, caducados.
(El director de emergencias de Puerto Rico
es despedido después de que residentes descubrieran
un almacén lleno de suministros del huracán
María - CNN)
Y no es la primera vez.
De hecho esta incapacidad para lidiar con
los problemas y las sospechas de corrupción
han sido una constante.
El resultado es que aun hoy, en una parte
de los Estados Unidos muchas casas siguen
dañadas y muchos tejados siguen cubirertos
por toldos azules.
Con semejante panorama seguro que no os extraña
saber, que la dura crisis que comenzó en
2006 continua hoy en día; la cuentas publicas
del gobierno siguen practicamente tan mal
cómo cuando se declaró en quiebra, y el
éxodo de puertoriqueños hacia Estados Unidos
ha reducido la población en más de 600 mil
personas desde el 2004.
En fin, ya lo veis. Entre unas cosas y otras,
la isla se está viniendo abajo. Lo ocurrido
con la Autoridad de Energía Eléctrica es
un buen reflejo de lo acontecido en este territorio.
Pero… Llegados a este punto, la pregunta
qué podemos, que tenemos que hacernos es…
¿Cómo puede Puerto Rico salir de esta? Amigos,
personalmente lo tengo claro:
Estados Unidos tiene que dejar a un lado el
paternalismo y permitir que este territorios
se gestione con total autonomía, para bien
o para mal. Al menos de esa forma los políticos
locales no tendrán excusas.
Mientras tanto cualquier plan de ajuste no
valdrá para mucho. Si no cambian los mimbres
del modelo no van a cambiar los resultados.
Pero… ¿Qué pensais vosotros? Si os parece
dejadme vuestra opinión en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ya sabeis, si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no dejeis de darle al boton de
like.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.